So that what we see here is an echo
in some sense of what happens in the
Mesopotamian creation story.
When [inaudible]
in the Mesopotamian creation story,
there's the dragon of chaos
tie amat and her consort.
Um,
absolutely
freshwater and saltwater respectively
in they're mingled together.
And,
and that combination of chaos and order
gives rise to the first assembly of the
ancient gods.
And then the ancient gods
kill Appsu casually and
foolishly and enrage tie a mat
with their foolishness and ignorance.
And she comes back with a vengeance
in the meantime.
And then she produces this huge army of
monsters and puts Kingu the worst of the
monsters out its head and the decide
she's going to take out her creation.
And so that's a little warning from 3000
years ago about foolishly undermining
your tradition.
So anyways,
the gods in their friends,
they go out and try to
fight against tie mountain.
They come back with their tails
between their legs continually,
but then a new God appears on
the scene and that's Marduk.
And he's got eyes all the way around his
head and he can speak words of magic.
And they know that there's
something new about this newest God.
It's his capacity for vision in
this capacity for articulate speech.
And so they say,
well,
why don't you go out and
try to deal with the chaos?
And Martech says,
yeah,
okay,
no problem,
but here's the deal.
You elect me talk God,
and now I determine the
destiny of the world.
And so they're desperate because like ty,
Matt is coming to get them.
That's chaos with the worst
of all possible monsters.
They're probably thinking
he's not going to win anyways.
And so they agree and out he
goes and he confronts timeout,
who's the goddess of chaos and he cuts
her into pieces and he makes the world
out of her pieces.
And one of his names is he who makes
ingenious things out of the combat with
tire math,
which is so interesting.
That's such a remarkable,
that's a remarkable bit of nomenclature.
So who's should be at the pinnacle?
Okay?
The forest that sees and speaks and
goes out to confront chaos voluntarily.
You know how many years it
took people to figure that out.
That's like the pinnacle
discovery of humanity.
That's what that is.
And it's echoed here.
You know,
you see Simeon and Levi,
they're too angry.
The other brothers,
they all have flaws and faults of various
sorts and so they're not elevated to
the highest place.
But Joseph,
because he has his coat of many colors
and because he lands on his feet,
no matter where he goes,
and because he's not resentful and
bitter and malevolent and genocidal and,
and he's not shaking his fist at the
sky or yelling at God because of Trump.
Let's say Dan,
he's the,
he's the right,
he's the right representative
of the 12 tribes.
And so that's brilliant.
It's a brilliant story.
All these are the 12 tribes
of Israel and this is it.
That their farther spake
unto them and blessed them.
Everyone according to his blessing,
he blessed them
when Jake had been made an
end of commanding his son.
So it's the last thing he does to state.
He knows that these are
the 12 tribes that will
progress into the future of this
people and now he's trying it.
The last thing he does is to try to
hierarchically organize their relative
virtues as an indication
of what has been learned.
And when Jacob has made an
end of commanding his sons,
he gathered up his feet into the bed and
yielded up the ghost and was gathered
unto his people.
And Joseph fell upon his father's
face and wept upon him and kissed him.
And Joseph commanded his servants to the
physicians to embalm his father and the
physicians embalmed Israel.
And when the days of
his morning we're past,
Joseph's spake unto the
house of Pharaoh saying,
if now I have found grace in your eyes,
speak,
I pray you in the ears of Pharaoh saying,
my father made me swear a saying low.
I die in my grave,
which I have digged for
me in the land of Canaan,
their shelter,
I'll bury me now.
Therefore let me go up.
I pray thee and bury my
father and I will come again.
And Pharaoh said,
go up and burry thy father.
According as he made the swear for her,
son's carried him into the land of Canaan
and bury them in the cave of the field
of Mac,
Pella,
which Abraham bought with the
field for a possession of the,
of burying place of effort on the Hittite
before mammary and Joseph returned
into Egypt,
he and his brother and all that went up
to him and that all and all that went up
with him to bury his
father after he is brewed,
after he had buried his father.
And when Joseph's brethren saw
that their father was dead,
they said,
Joseph will now hate us and
we'll certainly pay back
to us all the evil which we
did unto him.
And they sent a messenger saying they
father did command before he died,
saying four shall ye say unto Joseph,
forgive.
I pray thee now the trespass of thy
Brethren and their sin pretty sniffily,
really,
for they did unto thee evil.
And now we pray thee.
Forgive the trespass of the
servants of the God of thy Father.
And Joseph wept when they spake unto him.
And his brethren also went
and fell down before his face.
And they said,
behold,
we be thy servants.
And Joseph said unto them,
fear not for am I in the place of God,
but as for you,
you thought evil against me.
But God meant it unto good to bring,
to pass,
as it is this day,
to save much people alive
now,
therefore,
fear you not,
I will nourish you and your little ones.
And he comforted them and
spake kindly unto them.
So the,
the idea there is that
there is no evil,
so evil that good cannot triumph over it.
And Joseph dwelt in Egypt.
He and his father's house,
and Joseph lived 110 years,
and Joseph saw frms children
of the third generation,
the children also of Makir,
the son of Manhasset were
brought up upon Joseph's knees.
And Joseph said unto his brethren,
I die,
and God will surely visit you and bring
you out of this land unto the land where
he swear to Abraham,
to Isaac,
and Jacob and Joseph took an oath
of the children of Israel saying,
God will surely visit you and she'll end.
You shall carry my bones from hence.
So Joseph died being a 110 years old,
and they embalmed him and he
was put into a coffin in Egypt.
And that's genesis.